today's topic journalism so I think
there's a video that I think everybody
needs to see I'm looking at the
journalist Felicia and she is somebody
who has gone through us all herself and
she said that in the Washington Post she
released an article a couple of years
ago detailing her experience so as a
journalist which is not what we do we
are a talk show with the bring you word
so as a journalist it's our job to
objectively report the news I know that
that would be tough of you're someone
who survived sexual assault but when I'm
looking at this story she didn't give
the story any context and she got upset
that she was being attacked on Twitter
for tweeting a link that basically was
condemning Kobe's character and accusing
him of rape but I think her job as a
journalist was to put that in context
you have the responsibility and you need
to have the journalistic acumen to write
the full story go to the Washington Post
and say this man is a nuanced character
this man has a detailed layered history
that we need to discuss but don't just
tweet that out and be the political
reporter for The Washington Post and
tweet that and leave it there because
you're leaving yourself open to the
attacks that you're now receiving and so
whether or not she should be fired you
know I think that she should be put on
leave like she was I think it's
inappropriate because we're in a time
where we don't know what journalism is
anymore we have our president that
attacks journalists we have TMZ that
broke the news to Vanessa Bryant that
her husband passed away you know what
are we doing now that we need to look at
ourselves people who call themselves
journalists we have journalists
attacking a seven-year-old child which
is Blue Ivy and we look at them calling
out her characteristics we need to do
better altogether as journalists and I
look at this woman and I say it was your
responsibility just to do better and
give it more time than two hours after
the man passes away to say what you
think about him if it's negative and you
know don't hide behind somebody else's
article I stand behind a journalist
named Gillian Sheldon she sat at that
Kobe trial for six weeks she followed it
in Colorado in and out stayed there
interviewed all the lawyers interviewed
the woman who was accusing him and she
said how can we use someone's worth stay
on this earth as a referendum and on
their character in totality and we can't
because just like Kobe we all have flaws
there were all layered individuals and
we've seen this story time and time
again too many times when it's a black
man and a white woman that's an accuser
when that's the story and it goes down
and he just goes and gets convicted by
the public jury and we've seen the story
too many times where women who are
who have been sexually assaulted cannot
give their voice to the public and give
are not given the space they need to
share their story so this is a
complicated thing to talk about but I
really think that as a journalist if
you're gonna take that name in that
stance and that dignity of a position
you should properly do it properly and
just try to tell the complicated story
with as much care as possible and that
goes for everybody involved in this Kobe
situation Wow
who is she what's her name her name is
Lindsay Granger you Lindsay you mark
that with the precision oh you said
everything that had to be said about
that okay he was right ooh if I was the
one I [ __ ] up and that was my wife
talking to me like that I'd be like oh
girl you're right let's have sex
whoo whoo Wow that's some powerful sexy
every point I was made it's like there's
nothing else to say she said everything
that has to be said there's times when
people people nail it so hard you ain't
got to say normally we always interject
at every point but I watched that video
from start to finish and I'm like it
echoes the whole satine that I have
about journalism team this maybe I'm
both sad and grateful I'm uh I'm
grateful she said what she said and I'm
sad that she's no longer in journalism
and she's just a reporter great
journalism often goes unrewarded I
remember when the story broke about
Epstein people don't realize just how
much journalistic work went into it the
months and the years of research that
they went into uncle and now the only
reason you know about I've seen is
because of the few journalists who
worked on that case incessantly and you
don't even know their names but they did
so much behind the scenes work and I and
I took the time to appreciate it because
I know how much behind-the-scenes stuff
has to happen for a story like that to
break on someone that powerful and so
when I see people with journalistic
integrity I just want to say believe me
when I say your work does not go
unnoticed you guys are shaping national
dialogue in a way that's super important
and to the people who are not doing a
good job let me also say that we see
but this and what she's talking about in
that work we're talking about holding
people accountable because you encourage
people to reflect you encourage people
to see that the world is not black and
white that when I go to read article
it's not just gonna be some partisan
hack stuff based off whatever political
views the owner of that publication has
I know it's gonna give me a piece is
gonna make me reflect and it helped me
to see the humanity and people I
disagree with or agree with and that's
what we need we need people to tell
stories in a way that make us see the
duality of most human beings like she
said Kobe Bryant was a nuanced person
and what most people were so offended by
is the black and white but I could
recognize that that's a stain on
innocent act but it's not the entirety
of his being what did we say in that
video present the story as a whole the
context the whole car and when you don't
you are misleading people you are
misleading conversations and we don't
forget the fact that you lie to us
there's some things that you know are
unacceptable in your job that sometimes
just some errors that you're gonna do
that is gonna cost your job if you're a
surgeon and you forget like scissors in
someone's abdomen and you swim you might
lose your job that is something that's
normal you understand so yeah and so we
want to build their faith in the media
corporations we just need y'all to do
better so I was just so happy when I saw
this and I think it deserves to be
shared so you know go go hit up you know
Lindsey Granger on her our social medias
get show her some love and that's pretty
much oh yeah it made me Lindsay Oh
[Music]
you